35% of Americans between 18 and 45 you
have at least one tattoo on their body
upon your death those tattoos are gone
they're only permanent as long as you're
alive and then they're gone we've
changed that world so all of these
tattoos used to be on someone's body
yes every one of them
Charles Hamm has a lot of tattoos I am
the executive director and chairman of
the board of National Association for
the preservation of skin art we call it
naphtha you know I got all these
beautiful tattoos and I'm going to
cremate it when I die and everything
goes up in smoke so all the meaning all
the things that people know about me
that are close to me are gone as well so
Charles which tattoo do I get I can't
say but he hosted my upper bodies
cleaned so why would anyone want their
tattoos cut off and hung on a wall for
posterity
this is Shelley Craney she's one of
NASA's first members I was really
nervous when I first got my tattoo done
to show my mom the first thing that she
said when she saw it was that like it's
so beautiful I wish that I could like
hang that on my wall this is on my body
forever now it can be part of someone
else's story forever thanks to NASA
here's how it all works within hours of
a person's death naps I will mail a
preservation kit to their family the
mortician will then cut off the tattooed
skin and apply naps as embalming
solution the tattoo is then mailed to
naps US headquarters inside this office
complex just outside of Cleveland Ohio
this is where they finish processing the
tattoo it's no longer skin now it has
the look of leather but it feels like
parchment paper finally Knapp's a-- says
the framed tattoo to the beneficiary
everybody thought I was crazy at first
in my family but they quickly came to
realize this is a beautiful thing and
they've claimed their tattoos
I have a gorilla on my chest and
gorillas are known for protecting all
their females in their in their group
and my wife's name resides under that
that's my that's that's my way of saying
that I'm protecting my wife this
gorillas overlooking her so upon my
passing that put in a frame sitting
above a fireplace will remind her of me
every time that she looks at it and
that's really what this is about